e olha que esse contato com vocês
van e toque e aí a gente não pára tudo
com vocês hoje está uma desgraça
poluição sonora em mim tá chorando em
sim o homem resolveu que era hora de
escutar button galera agora eu estou
gripado a mexer não sabe dizer se eu
perceber uma coisa tem coisa que é para
deixar a gente puto meio eu acho que
deve ter com o pior do que você está lá
sabe se vê que a pessoa está online você
manda mensagem a pessoa continua online
e não responde ou em marcel tudo bem
como você está estou preocupado com você
porque você não fala mais comigo nenhuma
das fotos do seu pé e acontece isso
online vai responder vai responder sim o
tempo vai passando ao lay ea pessoa
aí eu desespero começa a punir uma todo
dia
meu bebê com um dia meu bem botar meu
bebê por madrugada pebble amor meu bebê
está fazendo meu bebê e agora está lá
conversando muito caro
o ex bbb que é dj nucepe núcleo de
medicina porque porque tu me trocar a
camisa 11 é a pessoa responde oi tudo
bem como é que você tá que deixou lá em
cima da mesa e foi almoçar não era nada
era só a moça eo pior é que nunca tem
tomado no pé da cama ou nunca têm tomada
no pé da cadeira só tem tomada num lindo
profunda terra você tem que botar
tomadas e tacos e lá e encostar na
parede ficar com essa pessoa é que tu
perdes a pessoa também assentados e
assentadas que eu to aqui né cerâmica
frio está dessa parede biquinho aí eu
faço não é porque quem criou a safou
satanás porque quem criou a ti zap
falcão mas eu acho que não era eu acho
que quem criou a tisa foi deus aí o
campo vai estar ele criou tirar a última
hora na visualização do whatsapp causa
discórdia a pessoa quer fazer raiva
outra tia onde mora na visualização da
tap ea mãe dela fica doida neuton online
online você sai do ar sobretudo a minha
mãe pensa que eu falei sim no meu site
what's up todo mundo das drogas mas é aí
que deu zica meus amar certo senhor se
tem que entender que quando santa mais
fechou uma porta de jesus abrirá outra
porque quando aquela pessoa tira a
última visualização do azar só que com
pés meus amarelo também não consegue ver
sua olha aí enchendo os acho que você
pode desenvolver com segurança como você
manda roncalli corre o risco de perder
todo seu da aaa e quando você manda
mensagens para gato nessa mensagem pagar
aquilo que você gosta e belezas e mandou
mensagens que seu zé sai do lado chegou
a mensagem você pensa que é ela
chegou a mensagem curta que pariu para
vai ver tua mãe e filho tudo bem já vêm
suas roupas aquela cueca que estava meio
cagada já está nunca viu
não se preocupe eu queria que você
comentasse aqui embaixo que você mais o
de lá e é lógico que se você tiver
gostar desse vídeo você faz que clicando
gostei que se você aplicar eu comprei um
guarda roupa e se vê aqui pra botar
roupa não vai ficar até um custo clicar
e mostrei isso é a primeira vez que está
assistindo vídeos meus engraçado né sic
inscrever-se toda vez que tiver um filho
logo você vai saber e nic br